motion is carried
right so we'll move on then to a report
from the
matera community board and we have a
certain a further set of minutes to be
received
and the recommendations contained within
them
to be confirmed
so would somebody like to move that
those two motions
be moved or separately if you wash too
counselor grant you moving both
okay so i was second for that counselor
heisted thank you is there any
discussion on the minutes before your
counsellors
there's not i'll put that motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
right we'll move on then to item nine
and
probably the most substantial one of the
most substantial reports that we'll
consider today but
more likely one of the more substantial
subjects
that this term of council will have to
consider so we have a
significant report here from from the
chief executive on a bit of an update on
what's happening
in that water reform space and also
a number of attachments that give a
really good sense
of the challenges that this particular
community
and also the communities of the south
face in terms of water quality delivery
and and i'll just open that up for
the chief executive to make any comment
that you wish
and then we'll open it up for discussion
thank you worship i think i've um
made sufficient comment in the covering
um
memo to the council uh the key thing i
guess is that
it's um reform is it would seem to be
in some shape or form uh inevitable
and the council will be asked to make a
decision
about whether it wishes to enter into
that reform process
more likely to be towards the end of
this calendar year
so this can this type of report and
background information
can be expected to be a regular feature
of
future council meetings as 2021
um wines and obviously
the big issue around this is
finance or money to deal with what is an
enormous array of
issues but what we are hanging out as a
sector
is more clarity from the government
about its intentions
so that all councils can make an
informed decision when it's being asked
to make
that type of decision which will have
a fair degree of compulsion behind it or
binding
a binding nature behind it so that once
you're invited to
opt into the reform process later this
year it will be
considerably harder to extricate
yourself from that process
as i understand it once you've made that
indication so
obviously to the councils out around new
zealand the quality of information
and clarity around structures
type of service that will be delivered
and what it might look like to the
average punt in the street is going to
be critical
so that your elected members can
serve the communities adequately
and while we didn't get any absolute
answers
as to what the future looks like
certainly there was a number of us
were able to attend uh the forum in
monaco
uh council heisted councillor bulger
counselling fail
myself and the chief executive and i
think there was certainly a lot of
meat put on the bones in terms of what
this whole process is about
at that that me that meeting and
certainly
makes you realize just how significant
this change is going to be
for the future of local government both
in the way it
is structured but also in its delivery
ability and expectations so
look the the report is open for
discussion and or
um noting and receiving
would somebody like to move along those
lines
councillor heisted albany's secretary
councillor bulger thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
okay is there any comments councils wish
to make at this point in time
council phillips
well certainly in in terms of the
discussion wanaka my memory was that
there wasn't any discussion about
fluoridation but i might be wrong in
that
and then certainly it's going to be
interesting to watch the fluoridation
space
going forward it's going to looks like
it's out of our hands
and we'll be told what we do and when we
do it
so we need to make sure that whatever
facility that we're constructing will
have the ability
if when and if it's required
to to do that do you want to make any
comment steve
i'll refer to mr sharma on this one in
terms of
what requirements uh within the building
would be needed to accommodate
fluoridation
should it be directed by the dhb that
we'd have to do it
and of course in that mixes there's a
potential reshaping of dhbs
on the on the cards as well so there's a
like there's a lot of moving pieces in
this whole debate
uh at the moment any further comment
as we are councillor bulger then
councillor dixon
hold it
good that's right um
going to inject
the speed of change what central
government is driving councils to
achieve
can't be found over the
on
i think listening to what we heard in
monica and reading some of the
data that's coming out of that and and
likes the reports we've got now
the sheer scale of the challenge ahead
of us
is is huge and we can't do it alone
there's no doubt about that
certainly in a short time even in a 20
or 30 year period
is going to put some real hardship on on
this community but also
communities up and down new zealand
council dixon i'm not sure if that's
working
yeah it is um i just think the report
made um grim reading for me in terms of
the condition of the
network and in gore's school district
council's network
in particular i mean i wrote i just
copied down some of the
negative things and it's just not
looking good and i don't know
how we could actually afford to
to fix all of these issues with the
budget and the revenue that we have um
i think the short answer counselor is we
can't no
not alone because it
obviously has got the oldest network
with about 10 years remaining of its
life so
it's um interesting
reading but quite concerning it's
concerning also to me that
that school district council could take
over need to take over which is under
review
private order schemes
okay um council heisted
um
um
okay any other comment or question
three waters and that's i think this is
going to be a standard item on the
agenda from
from now on is that right so there is a
lot happening uh in this space so
to watch the space okay we moved and
seconded that
yeah uh we'll move on then to item 10
which is a new dog pound uh for gore
and this is something that's been
circling around for some time
and needs to get underway so we have a
memo here from the chief executive
with some recommendations do you want to
make any comment to that
steve
i think it's reasonably self-explanatory
your worship it has been a project
that's been
a little bit on the slow burn in terms
of
um getting it to this point but we did
want to make sure that we have the
sighting particularly right
and also the design as well which has
been informed by a visit to the
invercargill city council pound which is
a new facility
but mr neil mia is here with us this
afternoon
to answer any of the more pressing
details or difficult questions
okay so the item is open for discussion
and or recommendation counselor grant
through your worship yes we do we do
know i don't have those figures
at my fingertips but we do have pound
records
and uh i could i could actually get that
information to you pretty quickly
sets correct this is this is dedicated
for for dogs stalker kept elsewhere
oh sorry neil do you want to make any
comments
uh
um
is
council phillips thank you worship uh
just a question neil
uh the overall price i presume it's for
everything including
shifting the power to it uh drainage it
back out to the
ponds etc is it okay thanks
council maximum i find the price of this
building absolutely
astronomical i've just got a quote to
build a shed
similar to this at waikaya for the gold
mine
and that's okay when i put the front
closed in but i was just doing some
quick numbers and i think we're a
hundred thousand too much
my quote put a concrete floor in and do
just the front of the building a
three-sided kit set
is 30 grand that's from a
regular builder uh you put the because
the golden rule
basically with kit sets is you buy the
kit set
this pit set here is probably 20 grand
you double the price
it's 40 and added 10 grand for the
concrete floor
that's 50 grand i don't
we've got to throw a toilet in here
that's probably
the most expensive bit of it but i'd say
no way i'd be paying more than 60 or 70
grand to this job in fact i'll be
grunting at that
if i was doing it
as is just excessive i don't know you
need all that space
the office why do we need an office
store room we've got to store a few
biscuits of the dog
things a cupboard would do for a small
cupboard would do for that
uh a bench i'll just cut the office bit
off
chop the building right down you know
we've got to
try and save money at this council we're
not building
the first five-star accommodation for
these dogs
a few kennels inside because i built a
dog pound that
helped that held 50 dogs and cost 50
grand
that included the kennels it was all
sluiced down into a pit uh all the
gold droppings you know that was the
whole so this this just seems
way out of the league in fact it should
declare a conflict of interest and
take your 175 and build it yourself
so look i i i take the points from
making councillor mcdonald
and i certainly endorse the fact that we
should be getting as best value money
value for money as we possibly can um i
i do question whether you've been to the
pound and seen the limitations of the
one that we have
and the expectations that we're we're
looking for
and the services of this one will
provide
and then i'd be interested to get a feel
from you as to whether this is a
reasonable value or not but neil do you
want to make any
comment
um
um
with the
situation there are certain conditions
okay so uh counselor guideline
um
for 50 or 60 thousand
and um dogs actually can be kenneled
outside on a concrete pack most farmers
would can wall their dogs outside with
say a standard crt kennels with concrete
pad and wash down
and um you've got a sewage bind there
that you could actually drop the um
stuff straight into with a pipe into the
sewage pond without putting a separate
tank in
um so the whole thing actually needs to
we look at because 175
000 in my feeling would build a small
house
tiny house and uh the other thing is the
site situation being moved
we can't share um we could share offices
with the um
the pla the plant officers for the um
sewage pond
there's toilets and office facilities
here and can that not be shared
especially the toilet
okay any council of mexico
super strong structure and 120k it came
um
um
just just just going back to my sorry um
three worship why do we need a secret
tank when you've got a what you call a
sewage partner right beside it
there's a question i was going to ask
too but i'm sure there's a logical
answer to that
so we can actually if we replace the
building to where the existing pound is
we could have fall straight into the
pond
yes
and that's what the whole purpose
okay is there any other council
council phillips thank you worship well
i'm
actually like to congratulate neil on
getting the price
under two hundred thousand because it
was uh in the long term plan for two
hundred thousand i'd just like to say
thank you and a person that has been
involved
in the pond uh and also the pound before
and i know its location and the
ramifications of the old pond
and with the legal things now that the
van has to be backed into the door
and the door closed in behind them
because of security reasons and i
understand the reason
why you have to build a new new pound
and i don't think it's a lavish i think
it's
thought out constructed and because of
where it's situated yes there has to be
a septic tank to pump the
the wastewater back over into the pond
because of the levels
uh i think the power supply
um if it was any further you would cost
a lot more
so yeah i think yeah well done neil
thanks
okay so there's been some discussion
around the report we need to
make a recommendation we have two
recommendations that are
suggested there for councillors first to
be received and council endorsed the
plans
so somebody prepared to move that way
councillor reed thank you secretary
councillor phillips
is there any further discussion on that
item does not i'll put the motion oh
councillor bulger
that much
okay so we have a motion i'm going to
put that motion all those in favor
please say aye against
so do you want your boats recorded
against that
so councillor guardian and councillor
mcdonnell opposed
right thank you councillors um
we'll move on then to item 11 another
fairly substantial discussion point
and one that's been going on for quite
some time and we
seems like we're sort of at the next
juncture in
in progressing this one so we have a a
a report from the chief executive and a
recommendation
do you want to make any further comment
to this one
steve
yeah thank you worship this is process
has been enshrined in the
2019 act that
former local listing p mr mark patterson
championed
before parliament to provide a pathway
to have
ownership of the otama rural water
supply
scheme effectively transferred to a new
company that was ultimately controlled
by consumers so for that to occur
there will have to be a referendum and
before the referendum is put to
the consumers uh there needs to be
information supplied to
the voters and to the council so
the information being provided to the
council
the act uh specifies that the council
must be satisfied
as to its adequacy
and that's one of the prerequisites
before we can put
the matter to consumers in a formal
referendum
so the information you have before you
in relation to the transfer
plan the financials of
the company and
the service arrangements it has for
providing
maintenance of the scheme they are all
the preserve of the council to be
satisfied
as to its adequacy the other point of
the process is that the medical officer
of health
must be satisfied or needs to evaluate
the company's
assessments of its ability to provide a
safe drinking water supply
i have referred the documentation to
the medical office of health
she has acknowledged the receipt of that
and
is currently in a week's leave and we
would expect a written
report on the information that
she has been received she's received uh
in the coming weeks
and once all that's to hand plus this
council's decision tonight
or this afternoon would then be made
available
for consumers to then participate in a
referendum
and have the final say as to whether the
transfer to
the new company that's been set up
should indeed go ahead
thank you okay it's open for discussion
counselors council heisted
yeah that's a it's a good question
and i i'm going to ask steve
your thoughts on that suggestion with
regard to
you making a recommendation to council
do you feel as though that you are in a
position
that that can happen well i guess i'm
torn between two things you worship one
is to
be a servant of the process and not to
frustrate it
but also to be a responsible servant of
the process and ensure that
the information is adequate
i have had a look at it
and was
comfortable to a degree but there are
some still some questions that remain
what i would suggest uh is that and i
probably would like to reflect a bit
more on this is that
we await the comments of the medical
officer of health
and then once we receive those comments
and bear in mind i've forwarded all this
information to the medical office of
health not just the
the water quality dimension and then
it might be that i suggest that
in a report to further report to council
that we seek
some independent advice on either some
aspects of the information
if i can't be totally satisfied that
there's been
all all matters have been uh fully
clarified to our satisfaction
look i think there's there's two
dynamics in my mind to this
particular challenge one is the ability
of the retirement scheme to deliver
water to the the various
subscribers that they have and i've got
absolutely no doubt about that
they can deliver water the other dynamic
is really about
the quality of the water and and
we as lay people are not in a position
to to judge that
and that really is why the the middle
medical officer of health
has been asked to to make some comments
so
i think the suggestion that chief
executive is making now and that we wait
for those comments to come before we go
too much further
is not a bad one
councilman garden i feel probably you're
going to delay the process because
we've actually tried to aim for a end of
june takeover
for the time of water scheme and um
delaying the process
she's going to have her comments and she
will first say and
um we've got to make a decision whether
we want to hand it over or not
and that's probably our decision
qualified people will look after the
scheme
and they'll be regulated by the
government just like
the core district councillors and
they've got their plan and we've got to
make a decision whether we go with their
plan or don't go with that plan
and um you know they're
not going to be um run by just the
farmers can be run by
attended or downers while more than
likely will run the scheme
they run other schemes quite adequately
we have to say we've got to let it go
look i think in terms of the ability to
deliver water you're absolutely right
the only question i have in my mind is
around the health concerns of the
of the water um and we're not qualified
for that but in terms of the just
operating the structure i don't have an
issue with that there's nothing wrong
with the health of the water it's
chlorinated
it's actually probably better than the
more water by a long shot
um and probably there's a plan
and if you read through the plan there's
a planned upgrade and that'll be
regulated by government going forward
no doubt and just the same as you guys
are upgrading
here they'll they'll upgrade there's the
kaiweary scheme the
other many hundreds of these schemes
around and closer
and they're all going to have to upgrade
council phillips thank you worship uh
just a question then did the
gorgeous council have any ramifications
when they um
passed on their adorama water scheme
then same principle wasn't it
sorry three worship yeah it was the same
principle though
it wasn't governed by a specific act of
parliament so this
this is a process that's been uh set
aside mainly because
um the number of consumers involved in
otama the other two schemes were quite
quite small and therefore could be
transferred
within the bounds of the local
government act but this because there's
over 200 consumers
needed its own specific empowering
legislation
and hence the process has been set down
for the checks and balances required
before the scheme can be transferred
okay open for you sorry yeah thank you
uh steve
just that then i um
when john had said about
other companies doing what they're doing
in my mind
those companies that do their work
are okay because it's all regulated and
for us to pass on
to those companies i i don't think
we shouldn't hesitate in doing so
because in my mind we
passing it on to a reputable company
that can do the work okay
council bulger
um
issues and provides a service at cost
but i do understand the committee
members consider that street next thing
the people of that
um
i guess the um the realm that we're
asking to
approve or not approve is the ability of
from an engineering perspective to
deliver water
and and i've got no problem there at all
so maybe
the medical officer of health is is
going to be that next step
and the uh the referendum can't
take place until that ascent is given
and i'll be very interested to see what
questions she does raise
council grant
um
no no no no the the referendum will
actually be presenting
uh an option for consumers to to vote on
and and i would suggest that all the
information that's required should be in
that
and i would have thought that um the
directors of the company would probably
be part of that but
do you want to make comment
um my understanding worship that pro i
don't stand to be corrected but the
directors
would probably be appointed post the
referendum
the company's been established so it
sits there poised
ready to be to burst into life and if
the referendum is positive
then there's an election process by
which or appointment process by which
directors will be appointed
and the company can be then be made up
and running and operative
council dixon and council davis
thank you worship i'm just wondering
about the potential for
council to become responsible for their
private
water supply schemes because that's yet
unknown so
i mean you could go through all this
process and then
it has to be handed back to council that
is possible
council davis
through your worship that would be just
a a simple assignment
from the council to the new company
and that's kind of it's commonplace
where you have a a consent holder uh
and the shareholding changes or a new
company purchase a company purchase
another company
and then there's a deed of assignment of
the
consent or permit to the new incident
council posted
is
okay councillors um
the decision is before you now so unless
there's any further
comments or questions of the chief
executive or staff
then i would ask that somebody
put forward a recommendation
the existing one
the council consider information
submitted by the time of rules scheme
unlimited company and provide an
endorsement that is satisfied with the
information submitted
pursuit two sections eight bar one of
the core district council
tama water skin supply act 2019
okay is there a signal for that
council of phillips thank you just for
watching
that recommendation was that you
consider so i think council gathering
you what your word would be that the
council
confirms uh
that the council uh endorses that is
satisfied
okay so we have a motion which uh
implies that the council
that states the council endorsed the um
that the information that's come before
us
do i have a signature for that oh we've
got a second uh
you can give absolutely
um ramesh has passed it on and said he's
happy with it
you are a counselor through your worship
um i i can't speak for
mr sharma but the package was put on my
desk for me to look at
and then i've just gone through it with
a
through a chief executive's lens not an
engineering manager's lens and
then invited you and looked at the act
and it said specifically the council had
to be satisfied
not not the chief executive
and hence we now find ourselves where we
are
look if i can i wasn't going to
divulge this in the public arena but if
it helps the council i will without
giving full details but i have had a
brief
exchange with the medical officer of
health
who i anticipate we'll have
a number of questions and some concerns
uh when she
returns from leave about the information
being provided hence
my suggestion that maybe the council
might wait to see what those formal
comments are
and and if the council wishes for me to
offer any evaluation
of the material independently of the
medical office of health
i could do so and then come back to you
with a full report
so um just so that i'm clear about what
the amendment is
this is this you're suggesting brett
that
council endorsed the proposal subject to
confirmation from the
medical office of health is that right
um okay
did you get that susan
okay so um
is there any just further discussion on
the amendment
does not okay
okay so if there's no further discussion
i'll put the amendment
uh should the amendment uh be passed
then that will become the substantive
motion
which will then be put okay so
those in favor of the amendment please
say aye
against engaged so
three against is that right four
four against uh so the motion is carried
um i'm now going to put the
uh it's exactly the same um
motion as the motion all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
excuse me does not the amendment now
become an emotion
it is now it is so this is what we put
yeah okay
thank you councillors uh it's been a
long running process this one
and um i'm sure there's a few twists and
turns in the
in the story to come okay
we'll move on then to uh next item but
our next items are
in committee so
i would move that council move into
committee for the